i think you
should chase what energizes you everyone
talks about passion legacy purpose
the one word to pay attention to is
energy i love that
that's it let's simplify this okay so
whatever energizes you naturally
expands you feels like possibility
is exciting to do it may be scary
that doesn't matter it has to do with
how it makes you feel
right when you were in your 20s money
made you feel good
it expanded you it energized you chasing
the money
that was the game that was your passion
nothing wrong with that and i
particularly want to say that to the
women that are watching
yeah because it is socialized into women
not to chase success like that not to go
after the money
and so if what energizes you
is amassing wealth go for it
but what hap and and the reason why i
say that is because people
talk about the word passion yeah or
purpose right
and the truth is it's not a person place
or a thing
it's not it is
the feeling of being
expanded and energized right if you're
pursuing your passion
it means that you wake up every day and
are energized
so instead of trying to think what's my
purpose what's my passion what's my
purpose what's my passion
instead of thinking like that i want you
instead to ask yourself
what's what could i do today that would
energize me
what energizes me if it's making money
figure out how to make money right if it
is
making a difference figure out how to
make a difference
it could be in any single shape or form
but if it energizes you that's what you
need to follow
and what happens is that passion also
because it's energy it dissipates over
time
because when you first start making
money it's thrilling yeah
thrilling there is nothing more
exhilarating than making your first
million
yeah nothing more exhilarating but what
happens is once you learn how to do
something
once you can do it over and over again
and so it starts to become routine yeah
which means it's no longer energizing
right which is why every entrepreneur
out there goes through the mode of
chasing the money and then you hit the
money that you need to make then you're
like i'm not fulfilled
[Music]
yeah and it's because you were energized
by the money and now you're not
yeah now you got to be energized by the
next thing yes well you want to know the
secret
the secret to helping any human being
it's actually really simple
the secret is to ask somebody
where they're in conflict internally
like what are the things that trigger
you what are the things that you
complain about what are the things that
you're afraid of
that internal conflict holds the secret
to solving everything and becoming a
better person
and all you have to ask yourself or ask
somebody if you're coaching them is
what happened to you now what's wrong
with you
but what happened to you that you
believe you don't matter what happened
to you
that you believe that you're not good
enough what happened to you
that you believe that you're not worthy
or that you
won't be a success right and everybody
has a story and here's the interesting
thing
you don't have to find the first one
because what happens in life
is something happens to you whether you
are a victim of abuse or you simply are
in a classroom and you raise your hand
and you say the wrong answer in math
class and everybody laughs and then
you're like oh
my new strategy is i don't talk in class
my new strategy is i'm introverted and
shy
that's my new strategy because i'm going
to protect myself and it works
it works because you don't raise your
hand and then nobody laughs at you but
over time
you start to feel that sense of like
there's something more why am i not
talking why is this
and so you start to have a conflict with
that strategy
and so the thing that you'll see is that
human beings repeat behavior so if you
ask somebody
what happened to you that made you start
to doubt yourself
they'll start to find 10 or 12 or 20
examples of it because it's everywhere
and when you finally start to address
what happened
you can now have the self-awareness
to create a new story to start a new
chapter to see the old strategy
and now consciously you talk about
consciously creating
consciously create a different response
that's what i do for people
i am helping people identify the
internal conflicts that are making them
miserable that are ruining the
relationships that are destroying their
self-esteem
and then once we highlight those we pick
a different
strategy right that's what we do and
you know anybody can do it any age
you're never ever ever ever going to
feel like doing the things you need to
do
in order to have what you want you're
always going to need to push yourself
you're
always going to need to parent yourself
so
what is the net advice on this what what
is the bottom line
the bottom line is no one's coming
no one no one's coming to push you
no one's coming to tell you to turn the
tv off no one's coming to
tell you to get out the door and
exercise nobody's coming to tell you to
apply for that job that you've always
dreamt about
nobody's coming to write the business
plan for you it's up to you
and because you're only ever going to do
the things that you feel
like doing right now or that feel good
right now
unless you understand that you've got
to parent yourself you got to push
yourself you're not going to make your
dreams come true you're just not
we're not wired that way you weren't
born that way you weren't that way when
you were growing up and you're certainly
not that way as an adult
and there's a tremendous amount of
liberation that comes when you accept
the fact
that you're always going to need to give
yourself a push
so the five-second rule is a
self-coaching tool that's all that it is
and it's something that i invented
literally 20 feet from here
in my bedroom although that bedroom
wasn't built back then
it was something that i invented to beat
my habit of hitting the snooze button
and the way that it works is very simple
the moment that you need to
do something and you can feel yourself
hesitating and you can feel the excuses
rolling in
count backwards to yourself five four
three two one
and something weird will happen
the moment you get to one you'll
actually move
and i invented it by mistake
i invented it during i think the worst
moment of my life which was
uh 2008. chris and i my husband of 22
years we were about to lose everything
wow his restaurant business was going
under i had just
been fired from a job my first job in
the media business
so i was just wallowing in self-doubt
because i
thought boy have i really screwed up
i had changed my career taken a risk
gone into the media business it didn't
work
out i felt like a total loser i felt
like i made a big mistake
we had three children mortgage to pay
um the entire house had been used to
leverage the business
so in our life savings so the kids
college savings i mean just
on the verge of losing at all chris was
sleeping on the couch
and i just couldn't get out of bed and
so i invented this
thing the five second rule one night
when i saw a rocket ship
fly across a television screen at the
end of a commercial and it gave me this
idea and the idea was
i wonder if i launched myself out of bed
so fast i wonder if i could move
fast enough that i could beat the
self-doubt and anxiety that i felt
every single morning when i would wake
up and it was really
that dumb and that simple of an idea and
um for whatever reason uh
when the alarm went off that next
morning what happened
is what happens to all of us all day
long
inspiration strikes so the alarm goes
off and use the uh
the snoo use the alarm clock as a
metaphor for those moments when you know
you should do something
and the alarm goes off and what's
interesting
is most of us don't have a problem with
what we need to do
it's how we make ourselves do the hard
so the alarm went off and immediately
my mind woke up and my mind started
spinning as our minds do
and i started immediately thinking like
most of us do when the alarm goes off
i don't want to get up i don't you know
it's cold i don't face the day
and then the body starts to kind of get
a little tense when anxiety comes in or
you start to feel overwhelmed about
you got to deal with and i felt myself
reaching for the snooze alarm like i
always did
but that morning i went 5-4-3-2-1 and
by the time i hit one i was standing up
and i was kind of freaked out because
why would something so simple work
but i went on with my day and um
i used it the next morning and the next
morning the next morning and then i
started to wonder god i see that it
works as a cheat for the alarm clock but
i wonder if it could work for other
things so i started to use it for
every moment in my life where i knew
what to do but i didn't feel like it
54321 literally just
decimates any excuse that you have and
as i started to use it in my life
to 54321 not be an [ __ ] to chris
five four three two one turn and walk
away from the bourbon
and not have a drink five four three two
one pick up the phone and network
five four three two one walk out the
door and go to the gym um
everything changed because my decisions
changed in order to make it stick
go brick by brick in order to make it
stick
go brick by brick one of the things
that's interesting about having big
dreams and big goals
is that oftentimes the fact that the
goals and the dreams that we have are so
big
it makes them really really difficult to
achieve
because you spend so much time thinking
about how big
the idea or the dream is that you become
paralyzed
in the moment around taking action how
do you build a house
by laying a foundation brick
by brick by brick you go one
small brick at a time and it's exactly
the same thing for your goals by the way
so if you think about where you're at in
this moment and you think about the path
that will take you forward to your big
dreams or to this
change that you want to make and i'm
going to use the eating program
as my example because this is daunting
to me
i can come up with a million reasons
right now just like i'm sure you can
come up with a million reasons why you
can't run a marathon you can't do the
singing telegram business you can't take
nature pictures for a living
you can't be more connected to your
husband which is what leanne wants
you can't launch that aromatherapy
business i can't possibly do
a structured eating program with a scale
right now because i travel too much
because i'm too busy because i'm lazy
because i'm not deliberate
like my bracelet remember my my intent
bracelet i'm reminding myself to be
deliberate which is probably why i'm
thinking about this program
the path between where i'm at and where
you want to get to is the same
it is a brick path and it is comprised
of a ton
of little bricks that come together
to take me forward and so when you think
about
a goal or you think about a dream as a
million little bricks that come together
and lay a path forward
that's the way visually you can break
down your goals
and so for me you know what that one
brick could be today
it could be asking chris or my uh
brother-in-law
for the phone number of the person not
even making the call people
i'm talking about breaking it down to
one brick so i will get that phone
number
and i will write it down in my little
red book or i will write it down in my
five second journal
and that way i will have the number and
guess what the brick is going to be
tomorrow
the brick tomorrow is going to be to
call the guy right
and make an appointment and then the
next brick might be to read a little bit
and so the key is going brick by brick
to make it stick because if you think
you can lay the whole path
between where you're at and where you
want to go right now you're nuts
my mind can be my worst enemy i was
laying in bed last night
and i had fallen asleep and i kept
waking up
and you know what i was thinking about i
was waking up because i could hear
people in the hallway kind of coming in
from a late night of parting
and you know what the first thing that
my mind defaulted to
there being a fire in the hotel and i
started having these visions of my
daughter and i
going down the stairwell and getting
trapped and then i had visions of us
being on the balcony
on this room and fire kind of engulfing
and what are we doing are we tying a
rope wish i mean it's just
insanity absolute insanity and i
i use the techniques that i teach you i
went 54321 i am not thinking about this
and
the thought disappeared because i
constantly reset my mindset
and you know one of the reasons why i'm
telling you this is if you
are tired of feeling negative if you
feel often
that your own thoughts are the things
that
trip you up in life that you wish that
your mind were more positive
i'm telling you that i'm the same way
just because i teach this stuff
just because i study this just because i
do what i do for a living
doesn't make me immune to what it means
to be human and what it means to be
human
is that your brain and your body want
you to survive
your brain and your body remember
situations that scare the daylights out
of you
your brain and your body try to talk you
out of anything that makes you feel
risky and your brain given that
it has been trained by situations in the
past and given that you allow it to
worry all the time you have a habit of
doing it
if you're not careful and you're not
deliberate your brain will default to
scary crap
like mine was last night that doesn't
mean you're broken
it means that your brain is thinking
something that's broken
and it's time for you to reset your
mindset and pull it back
one of the most important things when
you're in a situation where the truth
the facts are
that there is more on your plate than
one human being can effectively handle
on his or her own
there's a really important
moment where you have to surrender to
the chaos
that your life is for the next couple
weeks
things are going to change when summer
hits but
part of what i find personally
is that when i resist and i do resist
i resist what's actually happening when
that's not
the way that i want things to go and so
if you
start complaining or you start bringing
extra weight to all of the things that
are going
on it's gonna make it feel even more
overwhelming
and if you can bring a sense of realism
to it
so i call this and i think sean anchor's
the one that came up with this
this this term realistic
optimism realistic optimism
is a really powerful mindset because
you're not just putting a sunny spin on
a crappy situation
you're being realistic about where you
are in your life
right now and you are
still maintaining
an optimistic point of view
and what that means is that you
when you're an optimist you believe that
your actions and your thoughts matter
you believe that you can handle
what's on your plate you believe that
based on your thoughts and your actions
you can positively affect the outcome of
whatever it is that you're dealing with
whether it's being wildly overwhelmed
because you're a single parent
or terrified because you just got a
scary health diagnosis
or you're spinning because somebody just
told you they don't want to be in a
relationship with you anymore
whatever it is that you're facing that's
making you feel overwhelmed
first start with how important it is to
be
a realistic optimist so there's a
surrendering to what's so but you're
going to stay
very optimistic and positive and know
that everything that you think
and do is in your control and that when
you know that your behavior matters
it gives you a sense of empowerment
that's proven by research
super duper important it's also why
you can have a very hard life right now
and a very
overwhelming life right now and still be
happy
because you know based on being a
realistic optimist
that this period will pass and you know
that there are things that you can think
about
and do that are within your control
those of us that are out there in the
world doing big things
that one of the reasons why we're able
to do big things is because we have
trained ourselves to
just push forward even
when things are not the way that you
want them to be going
to keep your cool to um
roll with the punches even when you
don't have the support that you need
and so uh you know i had something
happen yesterday
i was in the middle of giving a speech
so imagine this you're on stage
you are 20 minutes into your speech you
have 40 more minutes to go
you have 30 more slides to go to which
is what uh
was happening at that point and all of a
sudden my laptop dies
i mean just blank you guys so i've got
an entire audience
i'm through the first third of my speech
i have two thirds of the speech to go
and my speech is a story that has a ton
of
videos and and photos in it and my
laptop
died and what had happened is
the av team had plugged the laptop into
a podium
that had no power in it so my laptop was
set up correctly
it was plugged in but it was plugged
into something that had absolutely no
power source
so over the course of the hour before
the tech check to when i was on the
stage
the laptop has run out of juice and so
all of a sudden
[Music]
here i am completely cold laptop i just
you know
had this moment where i thought the
first thing in my mind was
holy cow what am i going to do for the
next 40 minutes
and i could feel my stomach start to go
crazy and the butterflies to kick in
and um it just
wow um i was i was extremely
panicked for about a second and then i
was like okay use the tools
use the tools don't don't get nervous
get excited because you can show
everybody what looks like
in front of a live audience to have a
massive technical breakdown and not lose
your cool
and so i made a joke about it the av
team ran up i said look
you guys have no power here so take it
back there get it plugged in
and i'll talk for two or three minutes
while you get this thing set up
now meanwhile i'm thinking
[Music]
while i'm talking to a live audience
what if they don't get this set up what
am i going to do how am i going to fill
the 40 minutes when the whole speech is
not only anchored in the story but it's
anchored
in all of these photographs and proof
of people's stories from around the
world and so i'm like don't panic
don't panic use the tools now and then
all of a sudden the guy shouts out
what's your password you know because my
my screen was locked
so then i thought okay we're gonna get
this done not a problem it took about
five minutes
for things to get back up and running
and it was one of the longer five minute
periods of my life
but i got through it and one of the
reasons why i got through it is because
i've trained myself
to roll with the punches
that's what i've trained myself to do
the businesses that were launched by
somebody like
you who was working full time while
launching your business
had a 33 less
chance of failing than the people that
quit their jobs and jump all in
and the reason why is you know how to
hedge your bets
you're a little conservative in terms of
the risks that you'll take
which means over the long term your
business is more likely to succeed
you asked me how do i balance my
passions how do you find the time
because i like you have a million things
going on
from being an on-air commentator to cnn
to having an incredible partnership
with success magazine and doing a ton of
cool stuff with them
to giving over 80 speeches a year and
running a company
and having a family the key is this
you must find 30 minutes before 7
30 in the morning 30 minutes before 7
30 that you take it home that you take
at a coffee shop
where you organize your day and you work
on two things that will push your
business
forward 30 minutes before 7 30.
why do you need to do this well because
when you walk into work your day is
likely going to get hijacked
and secondly if you were to take this
time
every single morning and focus yourself
you're now
starting your day having already done
work to advance your business
and you're walking into your current job
knowing what you need to get done that's
going to make you work
smarter at work i think a lot of people
that are
working a job full-time and also trying
to launch a business on the side
actually have the time the problem is
that you're not
being rigorous and focused about what
you're spending it on
there's a lot of you that are running
from things
instead of running two things and that's
a huge
difference running from something versus
running to
something and so i want you to think
about that for a minute
um because you don't have to move across
country to change your life
and you don't have to do something
drastic to experience drastic positive
change
and here's the thing about running away
from your problems running away from
your past
have you ever noticed that when you run
away
it tends to follow you you know i used
to
uh have this problem in relationships
and the reason why i had this problem is
because i was a very unhappy person
i didn't like myself truly as a person
until probably
four or five years ago i spent as sad as
this is i spent the first 46 years of my
life really not liking myself
really feeling like i wasn't a good
person
really questioning the sanity of people
that were in love with me
or that were friends of mine because i
had such a low opinion of myself
and it didn't matter you know i i was
guilty not of moving from one city
to another but i was guilty of moving
from one
person to another that i
would literally get in a relationship
i would be in a relationship for a year
and then i would start to feel that
unsettled feeling because what happens
after a year of being in a relationship
well you got to start working on it it's
no longer the thrill
and the delight and it's new and you're
dating
now it's just you and the person in your
life
there's nothing new about it and so all
your old crap
starts to show up and that's when you
got to start to do the work and so
it was about the year or the year and a
half mark in almost every single
relationship that i would start getting
that itchy feeling
the reason why i was getting that itchy
feeling is because my past was now there
this new relationship was no longer new
and so i was no longer distracted by it
and i was going to have to
deal with myself in order to be happy
and so what did i do for years not even
just years decades everybody
i'm not i'm not proud to admit this but
i would literally jump out of one
relationship and into another new one
because another new one would distract
me from the fact that i was an unhappy
person
true story and i think a lot of you
who are unhappy with yourselves are
looking to move jobs or looking to
move the city that you live in or you're
looking to change your relationship
and the problem isn't where you live the
problem isn't your job the problem isn't
the person that you're with
the problem is how you feel about
yourself
everything that i have done since since
we launched a five second rule book was
in reaction
to things that were coming to me so i
never sat
out and said hey the five second rule
audiobook has been
a complete like record breaker
we clearly have an audio audience let's
go pitch audible
audible came to me which is fantastic um
i never i always dreamt about having a
talk show but i wasn't out pitching one
sony came to me in fact the only reason
why we got into
courses online courses and we now have
more than a half a million people that
have taken our courses online
was because success magazine came to me
and said let's do a course together i
remember i was there interviewing you
for it
oh that was i hated it because what i
discovered is
i hate being told what to do and so
but that gave me the idea oh we should
do courses ourselves
and so this pause has made me stop and
go what do i really want to do
and the the truth is i
want to go and make the biggest possible
impact that i can
and i want to collaborate with more
people
and i want to do events i don't want to
be the ceo
i'm a terrible leader horrible leader
the worst actually um because i'm
amazing at coaching i'm amazing at uh
creating i'm amazing at reacting i'm
terrible at managing people i am
terrible
at managing a project i have add i have
dyslexia
um i'm a bulldozer when i get anxious
um
we kill each other if we were roommates
or business partners but
but i think understanding yourself
is really important and so there's a
couple things that i've decided number
one
i'm going to consciously create the next
chapter
and what is that and i'm um well i'm
still in the middle of doing it
yeah but you're one of the events you
want to do these things you're talking
about yeah
yes and i want to i want to collaborate
more
with a wider audience of people and i
want to build a
brand bigger than mel robbins yep
i don't want it to just be me i want to
build
a platform based business
that uh reaches more people because
here's the thing that has got
that got me through kind of the loss of
the talk show and the way that i think
about things that i hope
helps um if you're listening you're kind
of struggling with something
um i believe and i went into the talk
show saying this to myself because
there's
a 99 chance based on the history of
people that have tried to have a daytime
talk show that it was going to fail
i went in there saying i'm not doing
this because
i expect to have a successful talk show
i'm gonna put
a thousand percent into it so that i
have no regrets
and i wouldn't change a thing but
i'm going into this because i know that
there is a skill
a person or an experience i am meant to
have
that will help me for the next chapter
that i can't see coming
feel the fear and do it anyway that
famous quote i want to tell you a little
bit about the science
so there's this famous neuroscientist
called antonio damasio
and he did a really interesting study
where he discovered that our body
senses fear before our mind even
realizes it and when
fear or danger speaking to your boss
calling a prospect
going to the gym when you're not proud
of the way that you look and you know
it's not
fear like terror it's more that
low-grade
agitation in your body i felt it
yesterday because i went to a boot camp
class yesterday and i'm
not in good shape and i don't do boot
camp classes
and kendall and i are staying at this
hotel where holy cow
everybody seems like there's some sort
of professional weightlifter or
instagram model and so it was really
intimidating
i could feel that agitation in my body
that's the kind of fear i'm talking
about i'm not talking about the
paralysis fear your life is threatened
and you really are in a life or death
situation i'm talking about the
low-grade
agitation that is
um there when you're about to do
something that makes you feel a little
uncomfortable
so when fear or danger is sensed in the
body your body begins a stress response
before your mind even catches up
and if you want to take control of your
life you got to take control of that
physical state and it starts with
catching these moments everyone when
you start to feel it i started
thinking about luck because there are
for a long time in my life i started to
think that luck was for other people
that luck was just one of those things
that if you were
lucky enough to be born with luck you
won the lottery
you got the job you wanted your family
got along and the truth is
there's a tremendous amount of science
behind
luck that luck is something that you can
make for yourself that you can become
luckier based on the things that you do
and the things that you think about
one of the things about lucky people is
a lot of lucky people
make their luck because they have
trained themselves to think
optimistically and one small trick that
you can use
in your life that is free you can do it
today
is when you go to bed tonight before you
go to sleep
i want you to write down one thing
that happened today that was good that's
it
just one thing maybe you got up on time
maybe you didn't have traffic today uh
on the way to work
maybe uh you haven't fought with your
kids this morning
maybe you got to the gym maybe you woke
up and for the
first hour of the day you didn't make
yourself wrong all of those things while
they're really little
don't dismiss them because those are
things that are good and the reason why
i want you to start a practice where
every night before you go to bed or if
you don't want to do it at night do it
in the morning every night before you go
to bed
write down one thing that happened today
that was good
the reason why you're doing this is you
are training yourself
to start to spot the good believe it or
not
training yourself to start to look for
the good in your life fundamentally
trains your mind
away from looking at the negative so
that you start seeing
this thing that's positive about your
life versus that thing that's negative
about your life
mal i got fired from a job i was really
excited about what should i do excellent
question
first of all how many of you have ever
been fired from a job
yep yep i've been fired from a job
and let me tell you something it's a
kick in the teeth doesn't it
there's nothing that feels worse in the
moment
than being brought into a conference
room
and being let go and then how bad does
it blow
to pack up your stuff and to leave it
stings
it is terrible it is humiliating there
is
nothing around it there's nothing around
that feeling even if it's a job that you
can't stand
even if it's a job where you've been
looking for another job
even if you know in your heart that this
is the biggest blessing in disguise
because you didn't really like it there
you still want to be the one to rip off
the band-aid don't you you want to be
the one to walk and be like guess what
people
i found a different job i'm out of here
so when
they beat you to the punch and they tell
you the truth that this
isn't working it's not working for them
it's not working for you and now it's
time for you to leave
it is still a kick in the teeth so i
want to be
clear about something feeling down
feeling embarrassed feeling angry about
how it was handled even if they handled
it in the way that is legal
that is normal it's normal because
it blows to be rejected and that's
exactly
what happens to you emotionally when you
get fired from a job i get that because
boy oh boy have i been there i have been
fired from jobs that i actually liked
i have been fired from jobs that i
needed and i have been
fired from jobs that i viscerally
hated that i was physically sick
going to work every morning i hated it
so much and it still
stinks when you're fired so here's what
i want you to do when you're fired i
want you to really
just relish in how much it stinks
for no more than 24 hours
you get to milk this puppy for free you
know
a free dinner from your pals at night
you get to milk this
and complain about it to all your
friends for 24 hours and then guess what
you gotta stop complaining about it you
gotta stop thinking about it because you
don't have a choice anymore
the job is over and i don't want you
looking back
i want you looking forward now before
you look forward though i want you to do
one of the signature things that we talk
about all the time and what is that
i want you to look for the message in
the mess what is it that you learned
about yourself
or about a job or
a boss or a um
or a kind of work that you
need to make sure you understand the
message of the mess because when you get
the emotion out of the way
guess what you always see about a job or
a breakup
that happens you always see that that
was exactly what was supposed to happen
that that job that that person that that
manager that that
focus that that was holding you back and
you were just too
scared to take the leap you were too
worried about finances you were worried
about how it looked i've been there i
get it
but you need to see the message in the
mess because i don't want you to make
the mistake and step into the exact same
thing
or the exact same type of job or the
exact same management
situation that didn't work the first
time because
part of the reason why jobs don't work
is it's not a fit
you see people get fired for a lot of
reasons some of the reasons why people
get fired is because the companies
are not doing well and in that case you
want to thank your lucky stars that
you're getting out now so that you can
find something better
if it's not a fit that's a more nuanced
reason to get fired but let me tell you
something if it's not a fit for the
company
it wasn't a fit for you either and so
look for the message in the mess what
are you going to learn about this
situation whether there was a skill gap
and you need to bring your skills up to
speed so that you're not floundering
your next job
or maybe it was a personality gap that
you accepted something
that in your heart you knew wasn't right
but you took it because you had to
or because you felt insecure don't make
that mistake again
if you want to know the five morning
routines that will transform your life
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe
and i'll see you there all right let's
be honest how many of y'all get up and
you just get your day started you don't
have it written down
you don't have a strategy you don't have
a real plan you kind of just get up and
say i'm about to tackle today
raise your hand for me raise your hand
we're going to stop